this episode is brought to you by house
of macadamia's delicious and nutritious
nuts holy hell folks I tell you these
things are delicious I've been gobbling
them all day anyway I love macadamia
nuts and have been enjoying them often
since keto expert Dr Dominic D'Agostino
recommended them way back on the podcast
in 2015. that tastes great and they have
more healthy monounsaturated fat than
both olive oil and avocados 27 fewer
grams of carbs than almonds and more
than 50 percent fewer grams of carbs
than cashews they're the perfect low
carb keto friendly nutty snack in fact I
just ate a handful of lightly white
chocolate dusted dare I say Macadamia is
about an hour ago to keep me going
through the afternoon until dinner it is
the perfect snack for me and I will say
this house of macadamias produces the
best tasting macadamia nuts I've ever
eaten that I've ever had by far that's
due in part to their location in the
mupumalanga province of South Africa
which provides the ideal temperature
altitude soil composition and rainwater
and pristine Mountain Water for growing
you guessed it macadamias House of
macadamias have partnered with the
largest Macadamia producer in the world
comprising 94 independent farmers in
South Africa which gets them first pick
of the highest quality macadamia nuts in
the region to make their one-of-a-kind
snacks like their vegan paleo and keto
friendly chocolate-dipped macadamias
they really took their time to get all
of this right and they've done more than
two years of flavor testing and you can
taste that in each packet you consume
and I've had two of those today
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show can
use code Tim 20 that's Tim 2-0 to get 20
off of all orders Plus for a limited
time a free premium extraversion cold
pressed all the things macadamia oil
with any order valued at twenty dollars
I love macadamia oil as a very high
smoke point we can use it for all sorts
of things it is perfect for cooking and
salad dressings and much more so that's
code Tim 20 for 20 off plus a free extra
virgin cold-pressed macadamia oil with
every order visit
houseofmacademias.com Tim to discover
some of the most delicious and
nutritious nuts on the planet one more
time that's House of macadamias.com Tim
foreign
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been in spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus with 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I answer your personal
questions
[Music]
foreign
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show I'm going to keep
my Preamble short because I have many
pages of notes in front of me and we're
going to run out of time before I run
out of questions my guest today is
Michael mobison spelled
m-a-u-b-o-u-s-s-i-n you can find him on
Twitter MJ mobison he is the head of
consilient research on Counterpoint
Global at Morgan Stanley Investment
Management prior to joining Counterpoint
Global Michael was director of research
at Blue Mountain Capital head of Global
Financial strategies at Credit Suisse
and chief investment strategist at leg
Mason Capital Management Michael
originally joined Credit Suisse in 1992
as a packaged food industry analyst some
of you long-term listeners will perhaps
recognize some of that from my
conversation with Bill Gurley and was
named chief U.S investment strategist in
1999. Michael is the author of many
books including the success equation
subtitle untangling skill and luck in
business Sports and investing think
twice harnessing the power of counter
intuition Edition which I've mentioned
several times on this podcast and more
than you know Finding Financial wisdom
in unconventional places more than you
know is named one of the 100 best
business books of all time by 800 CEO
read one of the best business books by
businessweek and best economics book by
strategy and business that's in 2006.
Michael is also co-author with Alfred
Rappaport of expectations investing
reading stock prices for better returns
Michael has been an adjunct professor of
Finance at Columbia business school
since 1993 and is on the faculty of the
heilbrun center for Graham and Dodd
investing he received the dean's award
for teaching excellence in 2009 and 2016
and the gram and Dodd Murray Greenwald
prize for Value investing in 2021 he
earned an A B from Georgetown University
and is chairman emeritus of the Board of
Trustees of the Santa Fe Institute a
leading Center for multi-disciplinary
research in complex systems theory you
can find all things Michael Michael
mobison.com Michael thank you for making
the time it's nice to see you again
Tim it's awesome to see you
I thought we would start with some Latin
that's my favorite place to start so she
is a is someone who knows very little
about Latin and I wanted to ask you
about your course and it's two
unofficial mottos so maybe you could
just mention those mottos and explain
why they are The Unofficial mottos and
what they mean so first of all there are
no official mottos so I made these up
but these are an attempt to set a tone
with the students but it's not just the
students in my course but really broadly
speaking in life
so the first one I mean the Latin is
nullius and verba which is the motto of
the Royal Society so the Royal Society
is the oldest I think scientific Society
in the world and it's been around for
350 years more than 350 years and
basically translated it means take
nobody's word for it kind of see for
yourself and I really like this idea
that a lot of the information that
people use or even things that they're
taught or things they take from
Authority and they don't go figure them
out for themselves and so this idea of
constantly having an open mind and
seeing for yourself and not working just
on Authority and questioning everything
that's the tone I want to set in the
course the second one is a quote from
Carl Gauss and I'm not going to even try
the Latin but it basically the idea is
Notions not notations
and the idea is don't focus on only
equations computation is obviously super
important but really the key is to grasp
the intuitions the underlying ideas and
then allow the computation to serve that
rather than the other way around now
sometimes you can solve a problem you
know computationally and then you have
to go back and figure out what the
intuition is to get you there but but
that's the main thing so I think that's
for example for business school students
it's a potential problem because from
time to time they'll run equations
without thinking about what they're
doing and they'll forget about the
concepts behind them so you know Charlie
Munger the vice chairman of Berkshire
Hathaways got this line where he says
people calculate too much and think too
little and I think that's what we're
trying to fight against with that idea
so Michael this strikes me as the
perfect segue to ask a question about
some of your earlier chapters and
specifically I would love to know how
your lack of business education was an
asset on Wall Street when you first
started out by the way I did take one
business class my father strongly
encourage me to take accounting for
basically non-business Majors when I was
a senior
and out of the complete generosity of
the professor's heart I got a C plus a
gentleman c-plus and knew nothing about
what was going on at all I will say that
I was in a wonderful training program
and there's a lot of remedial work so
folks like me could learn get up to
speed on some of the basic issues
but Tim I think the answer is that I
went in kind of wondering about and
thinking about being open to
understanding things from first
principles and Wall Street even to this
day is replete with lots of rules of
thumb and sort of old wives tales and
you know short hands for how to do
things and some of these things when I
would sit there and listen to them or
try to Cobble it all together just
didn't make sense and so for me it was
this idea of sort of The Beginner's mind
and really saying like how does this
stuff really work and you know I had a
for me a clear professional Epiphany it
was a two by four across the forehead
guy in my training program gave me a
copy of Val rappaport's book called
creating shoulder value which was
published in 1986 so this is probably a
year and a half or two years after that
book was out and it gave it to me for a
completely different reason had nothing
to do with the basic concept but I read
that book
and you know like the light bulbs all
went off for me personally and I very
much connected with that whole way of
thinking about things and I guess I'll
summarize the sort of three things that
he talked about that have really
remained the Cornerstone of how I think
about everything since one is it's not
about accounting numbers but about cash
and I want to get too much down the
financing road but but basically
accounting doesn't always represent the
underlying economics of businesses that
effectively and he was one of the people
to really emphasize understanding value
and how value is created second thing
which I think is really interesting is
that valuation and strategies sort of go
together so when you think about as a
business person trying to build a
business you have to make a bunch of
strategic choices but a good strategy is
one that creates value and to do
evaluation of a business you have to
understand the competitive position of
the company in the industry and so forth
so the idea that those are really joint
at the hip and you know going back to
even Business Schools we tend to teach
these things separately but they really
do go together and then the third and
final point which ended up being the
collaboration of the book we did
together is that stock prices reflect a
set of expectations and it's very like
obvious when you say that any asset
price right what has to happen in the
world for that thing to make sense his
target audience was corporate Executives
but clearly that was relevant for
investors as well so from there Tim I
would just say that I was sort of open
to that and I think that to me was a
good set of ideas to work with and yeah
that's why I think I was unencumbered
with any knowledge to be open to
thinking about the world that way
I came across something in doing
research for this conversation this was
from Farnam Street so fs.blog this was a
transcript of an interview that you did
Over Yonder and there was a line in
passing that I wanted to revisit and
this is from your earlier chapters yet
again in the early to mid 1980s Drexel
that's Drexel Burnham Lambert if I'm
pronouncing that correctly Drexel had a
great food industry analyst to this day
I believe he's the best analyst I've
ever seen so I naturally followed him
closely and then it goes on you know
shortly after I left Drexel et cetera et
cetera et cetera but I wanted to double
click on that comment so
if it's still true or maybe even if it
was just true then when you said it I
believe he's the best analyst I've ever
seen what made this person such a good
analyst Tim that's a great question and
I'm going to tag a bunch of ideas here
together the first thing I'll say is my
first job was with Drexel Burnham Lon
Bearer in 1980s that's where that
training program was and I just think
that there's a big professional imprint
on the first job and so Drexel at the
time this is when Michael Milken high
yield bonds The Firm was really hot it
ended up getting in trouble and then
there was a crash of 1987 so things
Unwound and the firm ended up going
bankrupt but at the time it was quite
hot and you know they had an equity
research Department I should back up and
say one thing in our training program we
first did some classroom work and then
we rotated through different departments
in The Firm so we really got exposed to
all different aspects
and indeed there's this one analyst that
filed the package food companies his
name was Alan creditor who was
extraordinary and what made him great
was he had
a very different view of things than
traditional so he was very focused on
for example Financial you know cash
flows versus simple accounting numbers
some of the things I was just talking
about he was very focused on things like
share BuyBacks before those were a big
deal understanding asset values and then
he had the ear of many management team
so he was able to talk to those
management teams and understand how
they're thinking about things and so he
was just the complete package and
interestingly here's the connection to
sort of my own career path one is I
mentioned my training colleague gave me
a copy of creating sure the reason was
there was a case study in the back of
the book about Quaker Oats acquisition
of Stokely Van Camp right it seems
completely remote you've never heard of
Stokely Van Camp but you probably have
heard of their most famous product which
was Gatorade oh yeah and it turns out
there's this little Jewel and it ended
up being a really great acquisition but
in part because they found this little
Jewel and built it into this incredible
brand that's the reason he Drew my
attention to this book in the first
place actually about this Quaker Oats
Stokely Van Camp thing so I ended up
learning a lot about that industry Again
by following this particular individual
and then when it became time for me to
become an analyst one of the areas that
I was drawn to logically was the food
industry so literally the reason I was a
food analyst is because this guy was so
good and because I learned and by the
way I you know I was a nobody it was a
little peon I had a training in a
training program so he had no idea who I
was but it just gives you a sense of
like how these little things happen that
almost like set the trajectory so it was
both his analytical prowess and so
happened to be applied in this
particular industry which is why I
became an analyst in that particular
industry
now hearkening back to my conversation
with Bill Gurley not long ago friend of
yours and he invoked your name as
someone who is able to connect
ideas principles best practices from
disparate areas and I thought this might
be
an appropriate time to grab a word from
your bio in fact it's in the first line
head of consilient research and maybe
just Define some terms consilience
what is consilience
probably not a good thing when your job
title you have to explain to everybody
and it's and that's really the case
so I was very taken in the late 1990s by
a book called consilience by EO Wilson
you know so we'll talk about that book
in a moment but consistency itself is a
fairly old well not that old about 1850s
probably is when that word was coined
and it's really about the unification of
knowledge right this idea of bringing
ideas together
so EO Wilson wrote this book he was a
Harvard biologist he's most renowned for
his work on ants so he's sort of the ant
guy he's also famous for his early work
on evolutionary biology and you know
there's there was some incidents he
wrote a book about sociobiology in the
1970s and that was very controversial at
the time at least
but in this book consilience Wilson
argued you know hey we've made enormous
strides
as a world in using reductionism
scientific reductionism right so we're
breaking things into their components
we're understanding how those components
work and if you look around you
many of the Marvels you see are the
result of that extraordinary capability
but he said as we look forward many of
the most vexing and difficult challenges
and problems in the world are actually
at the intersections of disciplines and
we're going to need to bring these
different ideas together from different
disciplines to really tackle these big
problems and so of course that idea very
much resonated with me so I'll just
mention these so consilience that's
where so consilient would be the verb
for that and then um this is probably
about 2000 or something like that and I
was just one of those guys who I and I
published from time to time but I wasn't
publishing on a sort of set schedule
and I'm one of those guys I'm reading an
article or watching a television show
and I'm talking back to it like oh no
that guy should be doing it this way or
here's an Insight that they should be
having so I was like you know what
instead of me muttering to myself maybe
I should start to write about this stuff
and so I launched a newsletter called
The consilient Observer and the idea was
let's look at different topics and see
if we can shine it in a sort of shine a
different light on it look at it through
a different type of a lens and so that
the concillion Observer series ended up
when you you mentioned a moment ago more
than you know the book that was sort of
the greatest hits of The concilion
Observer and those were all sort of 1500
word essays so they're short kind of
pithy it was hard to get really into
ideas but they were all over the place
as a consequence I think they were
somewhat fun for the audience to read so
that's where that word conciliency comes
from and that's you know again a big as
I think about the world you know this
idea of being able to draw from various
disciplines to thoughtfully address the
problem or problems that you're thinking
about
wheels on luggage bam how'd it take so
long for somebody to figure that out I'm
giving perhaps a silly example although
there's a lot of utility there question
can I tell you Tim I said to my wife I
actually think that wheels on luggage is
like the indication of the decline of
Western Civilization okay and the reason
is because because it used to be like
you'd have to lift your luggage not
carry it around like a little bit of
effort and now it's like everybody's
Wheels everything around so anyway now
we're two steps away from Wally if you
remember those people with the super big
gulps and the floating on the reclining
chairs and you get some of these things
are like tiny little bags with wheels on
them like all right come on you got yeah
you gotta have that one anyway sorry
about that no problem so EO Wilson also
for people who don't recognize the name
chances are you have latched on at some
point to a quote from EO Wilson without
even realizing perhaps the attribution
and this person's background he is one
of the most quotable writers in my mind
over the last 100 years it's just
remarkable how Punchy and memorable so
much of EO Wilson's writing is do you
have any examples from natural systems
or biology that you have translated to
business or evaluating companies
or understanding markets in some fashion
one is and this is really I think
probably one of the more common threads
through the research that's being done
at the Santa Fe Institute
is a study of complex adaptive systems
so complex means lots of Agents those
could be neurons in your brain ants in
an ant colony people in a city whatever
it is adaptive means that those agents
operate with decision rules they think
about how the world works and so they go
out there and try to do their thing
and as the environment changes they
change the decision rules so that's the
Adaptive part their decision rules that
are attempting to be appropriate for the
environment and then system is the whole
is greater than the sum of the parts
it's very difficult to understand
how a system works an emergent system
works by looking at the underlying
components
two or three obvious examples one would
be something like Consciousness right so
conscious very likely an emergent
phenomenon we have these neurons we have
this physical Genesis but the system is
more complex than the underlying neurons
themselves or ants in an ant colony if
you study an ant colony it's almost like
an organism in and of itself it has a
life cycle it's pretty smart about when
it forages they fight each other some of
our more docile I mean the whole thing
so understanding markets as complex
adaptive systems to me has been an
extraordinary Insight so the classic
ways to get to kind of efficient markets
is that people are really smart they're
rational so they understand all the
information they know what to do with it
and they reflect that in prices now
nobody really believes that but that
might be the starting point and then the
second way you know economists would
talk about this is this idea of no
Arbitrage right so in other words you
don't need everybody to be super smart
you just need a subset of people to be
super smart and when there are gaps
between price and value these super
smart people come in they buy what's
inexpensive and sell what's expensive
and close the gaps and and so in their
wake the rest of us can benefit from
these efficient prices problem is here
again they're just famous episodes where
these arbitrageurs fail to do their jobs
the third way to think about things is
complex adaptive systems and you know I
think that the way that's most is
easiest to understand this is using some
of the language from Jim sirwiki's great
book The Wisdom of crowds which came out
probably in 2004 2005 and you know the
wisdom of crowd says Crowds Are wise
when three conditions are in place a we
have diversity of the underlying agents
or heterogeneity right so this is one of
the reasons diversity is so important is
because we need different points of view
and different decision rules represented
second is an appropriate aggregation
mechanism you can have all the
information in the world in the heads of
people sitting around your boardroom but
if you're not extracting it and
aggregating it is of no value right and
then the third is incentives which are
rewards for being right and penalties
for being wrong in markets that's money
but it doesn't have to be money it can
be reputation it could be Fitness for a
species or other measures of incentives
that allow you to propagate so to me
think about markets as complex systems
is very powerful and in the ways of
crowds why are crowds smart and the
answer is when those conditions are in
place and then why do they go Haywire
periodically which we know that they do
and the answer is that one or more of
those conditions are violated and by far
the most likely to be violated is
diversity so rather than you and I Tim
thinking independently we sort of
correlate our views and we become
uniformly positive or uniformly negative
and as a consequence that reflects in
asset prices so that would be one
example May pause just for one second to
say I think the second comment after
diversity that you made earlier is
really important which is representing
different decision rules because you
could have for instance people who are
every possible gender every possible
color but if they're all econ Majors
from Yale who took exactly the same
classes they may actually represent the
same decision rules or similar decision
rules or how do you think about that
maybe a misreading you are absolutely
right and I think that the way I would
think about that and the way I read that
literature is there are really three
types of diversity that we care about
the first is social category diversity
which is what you just sort of described
right that people look different but
they have the same sort of way of
thinking about the world when most
organizations talk about diversity
they're almost always talking about
social category diversity and what
benefits of that is because we can count
right we can see how many women there
are versus men and so forth the second
kind of diversity is cognitive diversity
that's what you just described that's
really perspectives point of views
mental models training personalities and
so forth
nearly all the literature I've seen
suggests that it is cognitive diversity
that is the key to solving problems to
your point it's possible to have people
that look the same and think very
differently or people that look very
different but think the same you know
that's not likely right so there's some
correlation between social category
diversity and cognitive diversity but
cognitive diversity is sort of what
we're after and then the third thing is
values diversity and you know you could
rephrase this as almost a sense of
purpose
and here we want to be uniform right we
want that kind of diversity to be low so
we'd like to really have people that
have a common mission in any sort of
organization that would be the case and
I'll just mention that my favorite
researcher on this topic is Scott E page
at University of Michigan and Scott's
written a number of great books the
difference is his big book on this and
he wrote a smaller book called The
diversity bonus which is a shorter
treatment the same topic but the reason
I write I like Scott's work so much is
that it's not about hand waving or
feeling good it's actually mathematical
and he can demonstrate mathematically
why precisely this idea of cognitive
diversity adds value and so it is the
cognitive component that seems to be
that that diversity seems to be you know
so you want smart people and you want
diverse people and both of them are
important contributors to solving
problems or corporate success I'm glad
you picked up on that because that's
that's actually a very interesting and
important
point and I'll just mention back in you
know this is probably now 20 years ago
but when I was at Credit Suisse
well it was the time CS first Boston the
guy that ran the business asked me to
co-chair the diversity Advisory board so
we were setting diversity policy for
twenty thousand employees and you know
you sort of say like why would you want
a straight white guy to do that and it
was because that CEO thought that this
cognitive diversity argument should be
heard and should be part of every
dialogue as we think about you know who
we hire who we promote how we assess
people and so forth
I want to double click for whatever
reason this double clicking metaphor has
been on my mind so I apologize if I use
it another 47 times but I'd like to
double click on two components of what
we've been discussing so the first
that I suppose we could touch on
is
the wisdom of crowds or the stupidity of
crowds depending on how many check boxes
are checked and
one example real world example sort of a
classroom demo hopped out of me when I
was watching your 20th year tribute
video
which included many of your students and
there was a jelly bean guessing
exercise that you had them perform I
don't know if this is still the case but
could you just describe that and then I
have a follow-up question related to my
own audience
I believe the wisdom of crowd's book
opens with a story of Francis Galton who
was a Victorian polymath cousin of
Charles Darwin by the way who invented a
number of important contents contacts
and statistics
but Galton toward the end of his life
went to a fair there's a contest to
guess the weight of an ox
and you had to pay a little fee and
about 800 people participated a few of
them had illegible handwriting so yeah I
think he's had 787 contestants and
golton was fully expecting to show how
foolish this crowd was and by the way
he's got a really interesting it's a
nature magazine he sort of says you know
some of these people are butchers or
whatever you know so they would know
they had a sense of this but you know
some of these people were sort of
operating on with their own fancies you
know I'm in a good mood here's what I
I'm thinking about and when he tally up
the results it came out to be very
different than what he anticipated
essentially the collective so the
average or the median of all the guesses
were within one percent of the actual
weight of the ox right so this sort of
extraordinary illustration of that point
and so that was picked up there's a a
really interesting article by Jack
Traynor
t-r-e-y-n-o-r and Jack was a very famous
guy in the world of Finance he died a
few years ago and the article was called
this from the lady in 1980s I think it
was called the jelly bean jar and market
efficiency it's a short little article
but he described this experiment he did
with jelly beans I think they were
actually not jelly beans like they're
like actual beans and he did that and he
came up with a very similar type of
result so he was trying to explain
market efficiency through this wisdom of
crowds that that name wasn't being used
yet but through this idea
by the way it's a funny Side Story many
years later I was presenting at a
conference and lo and behold in the
front row was Jack Traynor so I'm like
you know I had to give the nod to the
man right the OG on this thing so uh he
was totally cool about it so I had to
slide I actually had a copy of my own
slides and I'm like Mr trainer would you
sign this I have an autographed copy of
a picture of a jelly bean jar
autographed by Jack Traynor by the way
one other weird thing is that I also
talked about that day there's a famous
social psychology experiment by Solomon
Ash do you know the ash experiment with
the three lines
but very quickly Solomon Ash was a
psychologist and social psychologist and
he wanted to understand the idea of
Conformity so the setup is you have and
they did in different ways but let's say
you have eight people around the table
seven are in on the experiment with Ash
and the eighth person is the subject and
the task is very trivial it's you have
three lines a b and c and then you have
X and the question is which lines which
of the a b and c lines of the same
length as X it's actually a very easy
visual task and in controls people get
you know they start with controls people
get like 95 plus right so it's not a
hard task and then the experiment
started for real which was Ash signaled
his Confederates to give the wrong
answer
and now instead of it being C which is
the correct answer everyone says AAA and
they put the subject in seat the last
seat and so by the time it comes around
to you the question is how do you answer
because you're thinking like am I insane
like I see this as being answer C and
everyone's answering a and it turns out
the reason we still talk about this
today is about a third of the people
actually most of the people actually at
some point go with the majority and so
they just basically override their own
senses and Ash talked about why this was
the case but this is this idea of social
Conformity and how important it is and
going with the crowd and so forth and
this goes back to our stuff on diversity
so I'm describing this experiment and
trainer raises his hand again like this
is twofer right he goes I was at
Swarthmore College in like whatever is
the 1940s and I was a subject in this
thing and he said I just want to tell
you that I remained independent I like
didn't listen to anybody else so I was
like oh man that's really cool so Jack
trainer was like obviously he was a
super important guy in the world of
Finance but there are two little touch
points that tie back to our two stories
one is sort of he made that connection
to to the Jelly Bean jars in the world
of finance and why it was important to
understand how markets work I think Jim
obviously came along I mean Jim sirwiki
the idea of the wisdom of crowds had
been around obviously to some degree but
Jim I think did an incredible job of
putting a name to that and really being
careful about saying as you said like
what conditions are the crowds wise and
are on what conditions do they go mad
and we know that both happened from time
to time
my understanding tell me if I'm
flubbing on this is that you replicated
this experiment in class where there's a
high degree of variance but among your
business school students
ultimately at the end they were within
say one to two percent of the actual
count am I getting that yeah no we do it
every year and we do it every year it's
like my little parlor trick and you know
it vacillates so in the last I actually
because I did it you know my course
started in January and we just did it in
January
it's usually somewhere between two and
ten percent I've done times where it's
been almost perfect but it's usually two
to ten percent and then the other thing
is let's just pick ten percent as sort
of a non-uncommon number what's
interesting is if you pick any person
within the group at random right so you
just close your eyes and pulled out
somebody's guess they're usually off by
about fifty percent five zero
collectively people are way better than
they are individually which is super
interesting and it's often the case by
the way that the collective guess
is better than any individual within the
collective it's not mathematically
necessary but that's often the case as
well so the group is smarter than any
person in the group my follow-up to that
is
what is the minimum effective dose of
cognitive diversity and if we find slice
it are there particular types of
cognitive diversity that are more
valuable for this type of wisdom of
crowds than others because in the
State Fair example you have butchers you
probably have painters you have a very
broad swath of society with very very
obviously different people in different
professions perhaps different levels of
Education in your business school class
I would think there is a higher degree
of uniformity of
thinking maybe that's very unfair but
similar age ranges probably similar
priorities they've chosen to apply to
your class or to join your class so I'm
wondering I suppose just to restate the
question
how much cognitive diversity you need
and are there different types of
cognitive diversity that are more
valuable than others for this type
harnessing this type of wisdom of crowds
I mentioned Scott page a moment ago and
sort of one of the ideas that he's
promoted is an equation called the
diversity prediction theorem and I'm not
going to go through the math but
basically it says Collective error so
how smart the group is
is a function of the smarts of the group
so how accurate each individual is minus
cognitive diversity so what you get is
the collective
accuracy is a function of both smart and
diversity so I just want to say one
thing just to be super clear that there
are many tasks where having a smart
person is better than having a crowd
right so in other words if you have a
leaky toilet or need a really hard math
problem solved you know by all means get
a plumber or a mathematician don't bring
in like an astrophysicist and a poet and
whatever right so that's the first thing
to say is that we want to think almost
like a taxonomy of types of problems and
there's some problems where just the
right person will answer it much more
efficiently than any of these kinds of
things but I think Tim it turns out that
and this is why Scott's things
interesting is it just ends up being a
mathematical problem that whatever
models people are using and you might
think about it this way it's not exactly
right but you might want to think about
this way let's say there is a truth
there is a number of beans in the jar
right and I'm the God God I know that
number you might imagine what happens is
people and like you said even the
business school students and I give them
some tips like you know here's some ways
to think about this you might think
they're going to have almost some sort
of sense of the answer some sort of
sense of the truth with an error term
and those errors might go too low or too
high and you can think about it almost
like a normal or bell-shaped
distribution where the mean is the
actual answer and that's what Jack
trainer was trying to how he was
explaining it which is
you have this this distribution of
outcomes and by the way the standard
error goes down I mean I don't want to
get too fancy but the standard error
goes down as a function of the square
root of n of the number of people are
guessing so it's actually less about
again if they're they're all skewed
that's going to be really bad and that's
going to be the madness of crop you want
them to have different guesses right
based on their models their
representations but a bigger problem
would be if there are too few people
doing it right so it's a sample size
grows and so you know I have my classes
probably I don't know 60 or 70 people
doing it golden had you know close to
800. so as you get that sample size
larger the number of people
participating greater it homes and on
the answer more accurately typically
so this is leading to a very
self-interested question that I wonder a
lot which is what fun or useful things
could I do with my audience because in
this particular case the N is quite
large and depending on the means of
accessing them but if we're talking
about social
podcasts and newsletter I mean it's 10
to 20 million people a month it's hard
to dedupe the people who are overlapping
or appearing more than once in those
categories let's just say but
nonetheless it's a large n for a lot of
purposes do you have any thoughts and I
would also say that politically
geographically from a gender perspective
quite a high level of what I would
consider diversity and I think
psychographically from an education
perspective probably a little less
perhaps on the education side I'd say my
listeners tend to be pretty well
educated but do you have any thoughts on
how to perhaps design experiments for
doing interesting fun or valuable things
with my audience I know that's a very
broad question
these kinds of problems might be fun it
depends a little bit of what your goal
is right if your goal is simply to
demonstrate how some of these principles
work and to use your audience as the way
to show that it would be super fun and
even something like a jelly bean jar
thing would be cool
I'll mention you know we're going to do
this in class I think the Academy Awards
is mid-march and we also do an
experiment with Academy Awards and I say
this dude I give them 12 categories
you know the front page is the best
actor best actress best film things you
might have a shot at getting and then
the back is you know best costume design
or something like that you know things
that are going to be much less front and
center and I just I say the students
don't tell me who you think should win
tell me who you think will win by
popular vote again the winner in each
category is the modal so the most
popular selection and once again the
Academy Awards the group does vastly
better than any person in the group so
there's an example that might be that
would be a fun one there's another one
I've always found interesting and I
think the financial times the newspaper
did a version of this
15 or 20 years ago do you know about the
two-thirds game have you heard of this
before I don't so here's the setup so
one of the things that's interesting in
markets but it's interesting a lot of
games generally speaking is there are
sort of orders of thinking right first
order second order third order
and this is an attempt to capture how
many orders of thinking they actually go
through so here's the setup you ask
people to I typically ask for a whole
number from zero to one hundred
then you hold that thought and you say
the person who's going to win this
contest is the person whose guess is
closest to two-thirds of the average of
everybody else's guesses
right so you follow that so you
everybody writes down their number and
then you as the emcee of this thing take
two-thirds of that value and then
whoever's closest to that number wins
you're probably already thinking about
how would you go through this right
mentally because you know you sort of
say zero to 100 start at 50 two-thirds
of 50s 33 but you know people are going
to go that level especially your
educated audience well two-thirds of 33
is roughly 22 uh but maybe they'll go
that far two thirds of 22 and so forth
right so you keep iterating down now
this is a problem that has an
equilibrium solution and that's the
answer is zero because it iterates just
down to zero the problem is and zero by
the way is it often a common answer in
my course when I do this and I say to
students like you're real smarty pants
right you found the equilibrium solution
but you're not making any money right
because if anybody rides a non-zero
number you're not going to win so the
question is how do you integrate other
people's decision making and I'll tell
you one other story about this which is
uh interesting so when I was at Credit
Suisse I was part of a research group
and it had a number of very prominent
you know kind of world leaders you know
former president of Mexico one of the
prime ministers from the UK prominent
Economist I mean this is like a really
erudite group of folks and we were
appropriately having a meeting in
Switzerland and we had a behavioral
Economist uh leading a session on risk
and this guy decides to do the
two-thirds game
and I'm thinking now this is going to be
interesting right because we have like
literally world leaders trying to
probably negotiated these high-powered
you know things
and they were absolutely horrible at it
it was like embarrassingly bad so I was
like oh my God I'm glad they're all
retired now but I'm like isn't that
interesting like I don't know if they
didn't get the setup but they just
hadn't thought through those levels and
so you know as you know in negotiation
but most things in life understanding
the position of somebody else
is really important you know whether
it's the basic concept of empathy is
super important right and so it's really
I thought that was a really interesting
little side note but that might be
another fun taking it back to your
broader question that might be a fun
exercise just to demonstrate these
principles rather than come up with some
sort of a dashing solution to a problem
I like the idea of
attempting some type of prediction
through
experimenting with my audience and maybe
I make it explicit maybe I don't right
maybe it's couched in some other way but
I do love that idea sweet we can table
that for now here's one other thought
you know you're probably familiar with a
little bit of this literature so Phil
tetlock and some of the members of his
team at the University of Pennsylvania
have done these forecasting tournaments
and you know they're the big thing of
course is this idea of super forecasters
so the question is would the Tim Ferriss
audience be a super forecaster right and
so if you gave him you know geopolitical
or economic events you know in six
months will interest rates be X in in 12
months we'll China do X Y or Z that'd be
super interesting to see and now the
problem is again that you're getting one
answer from a large group and so forth
so how easy is it to update because the
super forecasters actually update their
probabilities as things change and so
forth but that might be another fun way
to but then again that's what markets do
right so to some degree they're
prediction markets that's what they're
trying to do as well well I will allow
that to gestate because there are I
would just love to run more experiments
and then share the results of those
experiments with the people who
participated I think it would be a lot
of fun so TBD TBD but I will certainly
come back to that at some point
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by ag1 by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
what I would take if I could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
ag1 I view it as my all-in-one
nutritional insurance I recommended it
long ago in my 2010 number one New York
Times bestseller the four hour body and
I did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients you'd be
very hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient dense formula on the market it
has a multivitamin a multi-mineral
greens complex probiotics and prebiotics
for gut health and immune support
formula digestive enzymes and adaptogens
ag-1 makes it easy to get a lot of
nutrition when good Whole Foods simply
aren't at hand or when you just want to
ensure you are covering your bases ag-1
is the ultimate all-in-one nutritional
supplement bundle in one easy scoop and
athletic greens is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and 5 free
travel packs with your first
subscription purchase go to
athleticgreens.com Tim you can check it
out athleticgreens.com Tim they also
offer a 90-day money-back guarantee if
you are not 100 satisfied learn more try
it out athleticgreens.com Tim
foreign
now in addition to the wisdom of crowds
there are a number of books that came up
in the process of doing research for
this conversation that you've mentioned
and I don't mean to imply that we need
to spend a ton of time on all these but
I would love to at least get your take
on two that have popped up and there may
be one or two more but I'll mention two
one is Against The Gods the remarkable
story of risk and this came to mind
because you just mentioned
risk in the context of Switzerland and
the other is complexity by Mitchell
Waldrop from getting that pronunciation
right why are either or both of these
books
meaningful
or must reads or important in any way
so let's start with Against The Gods
it's written by Peter Bernstein who was
a brilliant Economist and historian
and it is the history of human
understanding of risk so it's a
fascinating thing now I'll just say that
broadly speaking I think understanding
the history of ideas is incredibly
valuable in pedagogy generally speaking
right so if I'm talking about an idea or
I'm using an idea today I think it's
very helpful to understand where it came
from who were the propagators what were
their blind spots where did they take a
turn One Direction where they could have
gone a different direction and so forth
and so Bernstein just brilliantly lays
this out in Against The Gods and he was
a wonderful writer it's a very
interesting book by the way he also
wrote a book called Capital ideas which
basically does the same thing for the
history of Finance so Peter Bernstein
that is money and if anybody's
interested in the idea of how we
understand risk and this goes back to
the bernoullis in the 1700s up to
relatively modern times
it's a fabulous book I'll give one other
backup one little step on this which is
it's a book I almost never talk about
but one day when I was a food analyst I
was visiting a money management firm it
was actually the state of Michigan the
pension fund state of Michigan and I was
in the waiting room literally waiting
for my meeting they had a bunch of books
and I just strolled over there and I
picked up a book called bionomics by a
guy named Michael Rothschild I don't
think anybody's I mean it's I think it's
a somewhat obscure book
but as a name would indicate you know
and this book was written I think
originally in 1990 and as the name would
indicate you know what he was saying was
the way to understand economics is
really through biology
and you know starting really in the late
1800s but into the early 20th century
economics became very mathematized and
in fact there's a wonderful book called
more heat than light by a professor
named Phil muraski which documents how
economists literally and I mean
literally mapped over equations from
Newtonian physics to basically give
economic street cred
so economics and finance went sort of
this mathematical
slash physics Envy route versus going
more biological and you know I think
that you in retrospect you could sort of
say that biological way would have been
a very logical way to go or as logical
albeit not as mathematically
straightforward or tractable so I've
read this book by anomics and I'm like
this is like so cool and the guy sort of
opens the book by saying hey you can't
really understand economies unless you
understand sort of evolution and and so
forth so I was very drawn to all that so
that's the backdrop I'm like sort of
primed I'm thinking about this idea and
then Along Comes waldrop's book
complexity and this is really the story
of the founding of the Santa Fe
Institute and by way a background these
two was founded in 1984 by a number of
scientists who felt and very prominent
scientists many Nobel Prize winners who
felt that Academia had become too siled
right so the physicist hung out with the
physicists and the economists with the
economists and the chemists with the
chemist
but again most of the interesting
problems in the world were really at
intersections of these disciplines and
gee wouldn't it be awesome if we got
these different scientists to hang out
and talk to one another
and so this is how this thing got going
in some of the early conferences for
example one of them was the economy is a
complex adaptive system right so the
idea of Economics being in there early
on was uh early days and so why this
book is so I think still to this day
kind of exhilarating is because you read
about these scientists and how they were
coming up with ideas that were far from
the mainstream and when we look back on
them now many of them have become much
more mainstream ideas but it's just it
was super cool and so one of the main
protagonists I think the book does open
or the story is Brian Arthur who's an
economist now and you know Brian was
promoting this idea of increasing
returns now if you've taken economics
microeconomics at any point you learn
about decreasing returns right so if
Tim's lemonade stands super profitable
Michael will open up let him a stand
right next door or charge slightly lower
prices and so you'll become less
possible then you'll have to match my
prices and so forth and we'll compete
our way down to less profitability so
decreasing returns and Brian pointed out
that under certain circumstances there
were these increasing returns there were
sort of these winner take all effects
this is now again he's he was writing
about this in the 80s and 90s completely
heretical and by the way like basically
the the mainstream economists wanted
nothing to do with it waldripped I think
in a very engaging way describes how all
these ideas developed and so if you said
if the Santa Fe instead is there a
unifying theme it would be sort of this
idea of a complex adapting evolving
system is a way of thinking about it so
those would be my answers those are two
wonderful things and
you know my oldest son before he went
off to college he did a gap year
and I thought you know like what would
be a list of books that would be really
great for him to to read and internalize
and you know I think we had a list of 15
or 20 books but these were both on that
list because I just think it's super
cool to understand the history of ideas
and it's by the way as a teacher if
you're ever teaching something
I think it's just super helpful to know
where it came from like what is the
Genesis of this by the way there there
are a couple things that I'm I'm
actually trying to track down now these
are specific Finance type of things and
I'm I'm having a hard time finding the
first person to come up with it so it's
kind of cool right to sort of go on
these little wild goose chases
so I'm going to definitely come back to
the Santa Fe Institute and I'll seed my
question now so it can marinate over on
your side but I'm going to take the
conversation a different direction and
then we'll come back to it which is
it seems like
value investing and value investors pop
up a lot around the Santa Fe Institute
it seems like Bill Miller value investor
introduced you to the Santa Fe Institute
and I guess the 1990s and then I've seen
a number of other mentions so this could
be just a misread but I wonder why maybe
we can just tackle this now why not
why it seems that value investors seem
to gravitate towards or be involved with
the Santa Fe Institute and I suppose for
a definition of terms if if you wouldn't
mind just defining value investing for
folks as well I'm not sure that's the
wrapper I would use but let me just say
what value investing is and one very
specific distinction here often when you
hear people say value investing they
think about buying things that are
statistically cheap low price to
earnings ratio or low price to book
ratio and that way of thinking was
founded by Ben Graham who taught at
Columbia business school and many of the
Graham acolytes were sort of these low
PE low price to book folks and they're
just buying you know against
statistically cheap stocks I think the
the modern manifestation of value
investing is simply buying something for
less than what it's worth so it seems
like all investing should be value
investing right if it's done
intelligently so I think that's the
distinction but to your point I think
that the Santa Fe Institute I mean there
are two reasons that I've always found
it so exciting one is the ideas that
come out of it
and the second is and perhaps even more
important from my point of view is the
type of people that tend to be drawn
there
many academics are perfectly happy to
stay in their Lanes right and in fact
much of Academia is a line to encourage
you to do that for promotion and
recognition and so forth and so the type
of people
that go to Santa Fe are massively
self-selected to be interested have
polymath type Tendencies and by the way
investors are a really fun group as you
know investors are a fun group to hang
out with in part because they tend to be
curious people and are the curious as
the main the main adjective I would use
to describe most of the great investors
that I know and they're Learners right
so they almost all the people read a lot
and try to think about things so you
know Bill Miller is a great example
Bill's been extraordinary in my life you
think about different people along the
way that have been really important he's
certainly been that for me he introduced
me to The Institute as you pointed out
in the 1990s we're at a baseball game
we're sitting there and he talked about
it but that's a guy that you know reads
all over the place reads very widely
reads different disciplines and thinks a
lot about how those ideas might apply
how he might be to apply those ideas to
areas of markets you mentioned Bill
girl's adventure capitalist right you
wouldn't really call venture capitalist
the value investor in the classic sense
but you certainly would say they're
trying to buy things for less than what
they're worth and and cultivate them to
some degree and he got all these ideas
cracked all these ideas as well Josh
Wolf is on our board you know so we have
a lot of really I think the connection
between all these folks the thread is is
this idea of intellectual curiosity and
a willingness to pursue that Curiosity
by by immersing yourself in that type of
environment I'll add one thing to the
investor comment which is part of the
reason I enjoy if not spending time with
at least observing and studying
investors because they also have a
report card in a lot of cases right so
they are placing bets based on their
thinking
so it's not simply opinion versus
opinion you can look at the returns at
least for some of them which I find very
very refreshing I also really appreciate
that aspect of interacting with or at
least studying a lot of investors and in
preparation for this conversation like
also shot texts to two mutual
acquaintances
both thinkers I respect greatly Josh
waitskin and Patrick O'Shaughnessy so I
wanted to actually
grab a few of the possible questions
that Patrick had forwarded also great
podcaster I recommend people check out
Patrick's podcast and you can feel free
to decline divert or transmogrify this
however you like but he sent me quite a
few things and we'll probably dig into a
number of them but I thought one that
would be fun for listeners and I include
myself in that group is the following an
asset class tour with him could be
really fun in other words how do you
think about private Equity Venture
credit public Equity Cash Gold real
estate and what they do for you when
done well in the role they can play is
that a Sandbox you're willing to hop
into for a little bit well I mean it's
just something I don't I actually don't
know that much about but I could
probably make one or two comments
one of my covid projects was in 2020
was to do a big piece on public to
private equity and we needed to find a
bunch of things just get out of the way
so public equities are just stocks of
traded in the United States today
they're around 3 500 of them roughly
speaking what's fascinating is there are
about as half as many companies that
trade public companies that trade today
as there were in the mid 1990s and
they're in fact less than they were in
the 1970s
so obviously our economy is bigger our
population's bigger right you would
expect the number of public companies to
roughly grow in line with all those
other metrics but that has not been the
case so that's an interesting thing like
in and of itself why is that and at the
same time we've seen the emergence of
private Equity now private Equity is a a
wrapper that really covers two different
areas one is buyouts
and in a buyout typically a sponsor will
buy a company usually using leverage and
then own it for typically five years or
so and then try to sell it for a profit
but the key there is that they buy
stable businesses typically with lots of
cash flow venture capital is the other
side of that which is buying very young
companies often when they're just
getting going and actually playing a
very important role in fostering that
development so being on the board giving
guidance and so on so forth right so a
couple observations that come out of
that that are interesting one is why are
there fewer companies and and basically
the simple answer is there have been
lots of mergers and Acquisitions and not
a lot of IPOs so part of it's the cost
of IPOs have gone up and so there are
simply fewer public companies than there
used to be the flip side is they're much
bigger now and more profitable on
average and so forth so that's
interesting and then the second thing
I'll just say Tim this is just me sort
of speculating a bit which is
roughly speaking at last say since 1980
so it's called the last 40 years or so
there's been roughly maybe we've
reversed this in the last year or two
but roughly a steady decline in interest
rates
that means your expected returns
basically go down right because you put
money in the bank or invest in something
you get lesser expected return and at
the same time our liabilities are going
up right if you have to put a kid
through college or you're thinking I'm
just playing your own retirement right
you're expected to live longer and so
forth so your liabilities aren't going
down so if the expected returns are
going down the liabilities are going up
like what do you do about that and the
answer is typically you go out on the
risk Spectrum you take on more risk and
how do you take on more risks the answer
is there are two interesting ways to do
that one is to use more financial
leverage right more debt and that's what
buyouts do specifically and the second
is to buy Young companies that are
inherently riskier companies and that's
Venture Capital so I think part of the
answer of the emergence of those two
segments those asset classes is
precisely to accommodate that basic
reality that returns in more public
markets have been less exciting than
they have been in the past some of the
other ones you mentioned like credit or
or gold or whatever I don't really have
much to say about those things okay well
we can park those I would
like to transition then to base rates so
the power of Base rates in life and
business slash investing and the prompt
that I got was something related to one
of the famous Triple Crown horses
if that is enough of a catalyst to get
the party started then I'll let you know
let's start the party let me just say
Tim that if if there were an idea that I
could go back and tell my young self my
18 year old self it would be this idea
of Base rates
I learned about this from Danny Kahneman
he used slightly different language but
we'll lay out the terms and go back and
forth
so common used this idea of the inside
versus the outside View and the outside
view is base rates okay so here's the
basic setup
if I present you with a problem it could
be almost any kind of problem you know
how long will it take you to remodel
your kitchen and what will it cost when
will you be done with your book
manuscript you know you're a college
student when will you be done with your
term paper or your problem set or
whatever it is right the standard way to
think about that is to gather a bunch of
information right so think about it
combine it with your own inputs and then
project and like left our own devices
that's how we all do these things that's
called the inside view the outside view
or the base rates by contrast says I'm
going to think about my problem as an
instance of a larger reference class I'm
going to ask a really simple question
like what happened when other people
were in this situation before and it's a
very unnatural way to think about the
world right for a couple reasons first
is you have to leave aside like your own
views and your own cherished information
right which we tend to place a
disproportionate amount of weight on and
then second is you have to find an
appeal to this base rate and it may not
be at your fingertips or you may not
even think about it that overtly
but what psychologists have demonstrated
and it's not all one or the other but
some thoughtful combination of the
inside versus the outside view sort of
your own analysis versus base rates
tends to lead to better and more
accurate predictions
and this is sort of as a real time I
don't know what year this was 2008 2009
something like that
there was a horse running for the Triple
Crown so right the first race is the
Kentucky Derby and it won the race by
like four and a half lengths big brown
this is the second leg is the Preakness
it's in Baltimore it was Stronger still
I think it run by one by like five
lengths or something so it's One race
away from horse racing immortality which
is pretty impressive now the last race
is the Belmont it's the longest which is
difficult so many horses are actually
quite fast they're sprinters longer
distances are more challenging for them
but big brown was obviously sort of the
the favorite appropriately so
and he went off at odds it suggested a
77 probability of winning the Belmont 77
so the question is like all right How
likely it is it that he's going to win
at that probability and what you do is
you look at base rates and you ask how
many of the horses in a position to win
the Triple Crown
what percent actually did that there
have been Triple Crown winners since
this so this is the date at the time at
the time there had been I think there
was like 28 or 29 horses that had tried
40 percent had succeeded so 40 is really
a lot lower than 77. but what's
interesting is that eight of the nine
horses had tried before 1950 succeeded
and only three of the 20 since 1958
succeeded so it was a 15 success rate
since 1950.
all right so you're like okay well
that's an interesting data point he's
going off at 77 now it's okay and then
the second thing is maybe there's just
like a wicked fast horse right maybe
this is like the new Secretariat and
there's a way to measure that it's
called a buyer speed figure and speed
figures really haven't been kept
accurately since the 19 uh they I think
they started about 1990 so about 30
years call it at the time was probably
more like 20 years and this horse was
actually the slowest by speed figures of
the last seven contenders for the Triple
Crown all of which that it failed so you
know he's going off at 77 and of course
he ran the race and was made the story
sort of cap the story was the horse
basically took the day off did jockey
technically eased him but he came in
last basically right so the next day
they give him a physical you know from
his nose to his tail or like is he okay
she's fine he was just fine so the guy
was talking to about this guy named
Steven Crist who's an awesome guy by the
way fascinating guy and a famous
handicapper and a brilliant writer so
I'm like Steve you're like what's up
with this and he's like people don't
seem to realize we're talking talking
about horses here they just so anyway
the story was he was a favorite he was
probably a 40 probability you know 45 if
you're using all these data but at 77
he's a Bad Bet and this goes back Tim
just to Circle back around to our wisdom
of crowds thing right so what happens is
this is a diversity breakdown right so
most people don't bet on horse races day
in day out they're professional
handicappers and people do it for fun
but for the most part there's not a lot
of volume and so forth
however when there's a Triple Crown
Contender people get fired up in fact
the Belmont I think the attendance
doubled from the prior year he was
really hot and steamy day and people
pull out their wallets and they start
plunking down their best right because
you want that ticket that says I bet on
the Triple Crown winner right and of
course these are markets that are set by
the dollars flowing in they're
paramutual markets right so the dollar
flows are what dictate the odds so it's
a classic example of a diversity there
is a perfect example diversity breakdown
perfect sense and again it's like day in
day out horse race results are actually
incredibly efficient and they're
certainly very hard to beat when you
take out the track take for example The
Vig they're obviously they're
professional handicappers but not many
and those who are doing it are very
sophisticated and so forth but you know
you and I like regular Joes we're not
going to make money doing this anyway so
there's a good that's a good example and
it's hard to short you could bet the
field or something it's but it's hard to
short a horse this seems a little bit
unsporty to do that but anyway that's
the big round but the broader lesson is
that no matter what you're thinking of
doing you know moving to a new city
taking a new job anything you're
thinking about doing is asking is there
an appropriate reference class is there
a base rate that I can look at to see if
I can get some information about a
little bit about my prospects where we
spent a lot of time on this is for
example things like corporate
performance right so I know you do a
little bit of investing as well but
questions like you know if a company's
has sales of a billion dollars like
what's the distribution of growth rates
I should expect right and let's look at
history to figure out how good could it
be how bad could it be what's the
average and then where do I think my
company's going to fall within this
distribution and you know how optimistic
or pessimistic it might be so I could
ask a million questions about base rate
but the one that's really sticking out
for me is what on Earth happened around
1950 with the horses it was an
anti-doping measures what what clicked
in that that led to that
might be the opposite it could be the
ubiquity of doping the Secret's out
this is a fascinating conversation there
are people I'm way over my skis already
but I want to tell you that for almost
all the big races the Kentucky Derby you
know because they've been run for a very
long time under the same conditions
right that I think the horses today run
essentially the same speed as they did
in the 1950s
they're no faster so I think that
thoroughbred horses are this topic is
fascinating of itself right because
they've been bred from a very very
narrow stock so they're a handful of
horses that are essentially the
ancestors of every horse that's around
today so the genetics are really crazy
and that's why they're such fragile
animals but I think that they're at
their physiological limits and they have
been for a while Secretariat was a freak
literally a genetic freak and as you
know you've probably heard these stories
when I don't know if they actually did
this but apparently there was some sort
of an autopsy in secretary's heart was
much much larger than was normal for a
horse like that so secretary really was
like one one in a multi-generation freak
but yeah I think they're physiological
limits so the horses all today are no
faster than they were back in the day
yeah certainly hasn't stopped people
from doping horses I know that is you
know quite a few drugs that have made
their way from
research to race horses to bodybuilders
to the billionaires who want to live for
a million years with six-pack abs
so the resources are have been a sort of
test bed for a lot of drugs for a long
time but it's interesting that as far as
speeds go it seems that at least the top
end I wonder if the averages have
changed at all
we can go look at all the numbers but I
would imagine things like Marathon times
or 100 meter dash and so forth they're
all I'm sure they're all faster right
swimming times for sure they're all
faster than they were in 1950. so it is
interesting that this is one domain
where they hit the wall but part of it
is because this goes back to our thing
on diversity right you have no diversity
in the genetic pool so as a consequence
you've sort of tapped it out so if you
want to build a faster horse you would
you'd have to shuffle some genes around
which has not been happening right by
definition it can't happen yeah I'm not
going to become a handicapper but I may
have to chat with Stephen Christ and
learn a bit more about this horse game I
would like to jump though to discussing
what separates good from great investors
and there's a line here that I believe
is your writing please fact check me if
I'm not getting that but this is part of
a larger piece but what separated the
good from the great investors had little
to do with their analytical tools but a
great deal to do with how they made
decisions and I suppose that's maybe a
subset question of just in your
experience in your studies
in your practice what have you found
most reliably separates good from great
investors
the analytical stuff is anti for the
game right so you have to understand you
know basic accounting and finance and so
forth so there's no getting around that
and that's you need to do that but I
think that quote captures certainly what
what I think about this which is the key
is making really good decisions and this
is particularly difficult under a bunch
of different circumstances that we could
talk about but maybe the two or three
biases I think are really difficult to
circumvent the first is overconfidence
we tend to think we understand the
future better than we actually do and
this is something we can test pretty
well and sort of experiments and as a
consequence people think about ranges of
outcomes that are too narrow and that
gets them into some trouble so
overconfidence and the second one I
think is even more difficult which is
confirmation bias which is once we've
made up our minds about something we
tend to seek information that confirms
our point of view and dismiss discount
disavow information that does not
and one of the vital things in investing
is updating your views and if you're not
constantly doing that and doing that
honestly and objectively or as
objectively as possible that's going to
put you at a substantial disadvantage
that's that decision-making aspect now
there's another aspect to all this
that's really important right which is
you ultimately have to come up with a
view that's different than other people
and that view ultimately has to be
correct and so there's a little bit of
an anti-social component to all of
investing like great investors is a
little bit of an anti-social component
to it you know some people I think do
that better than others or more
naturally than others but that ends up
being decision making because at the end
of the day often you buy something and
it goes down in your face even if your
thesis is correct and you know do you
have the fortitude just sort of stick
with that position
the third thing I'll mention Tim if you
had Robert sapolski as one of your
guests yeah right I haven't actually no
do you know Robert has the name uh you
should probably remind me
he'd be a fun guy for you to talk to on
many levels he's a neurobiologist and a
primatologist at Stanford University you
know he wrote a book called behave in
2017 which is I would say probably the
best book I've ever read on human nature
it's not an easy read
but it's very well written and very
interesting he has a book coming out
later this year I believe on the topic
of Free Will so interesting guy but
Robert spent you know for years his
obviously his academic years at Stanford
in his lab and then he would spend the
summers in Kenya studying baboons and if
you ask him why do you study baboons he
would say because they're
physiologically like humans and like
humans they spend three hours a day
feeding themselves and the rest of time
tormenting one another
but what Robert was interested in is a
topic of stress and so he wrote a book
called why zebras don't get ulcers in
the mid 1990s which is It's a Wonderful
title and it's a wonderful book about
the idea of stress so he's like a key
guy and I'm saying stress and so of
course in these baboon truths what he
can do is you know the questions he's
asking is like hey who's stressed out
here is it the alpha male the beta male
like you know the females like who's
getting stressed out or the low ranking
males and of course you can shoot a dart
into the flank of a baboon and draw
blood and measure cortisol so they're
actually they can understand exactly
what's going on at least this rough
proxy for stress this all a big wind up
to sort of talk about how you know
something is important for investors and
particularly time Horizon so sapolsky
sort of asked this question like what
stresses out an animal right here zebra
hanging out in the savannah right
pursuing to his title what stress you
out the answer is a line decide you're
the target for lunch bad news right your
structure response is going to kick in
you're going to pump blood you're going
to pump adrenaline and you're going to
run really fast what's also important is
you're turning off all your long-term
oriented systems right you're turning
off growth immune digestion reproductive
systems these are caloric luxuries for
another moment if you elude the lion you
go back to your group and you reverse
all those processes you go back to
homeostasis right now the question is
what stress is a human being
and we have a clear we have Apostolic
physical stressors and you've put
yourself through more than your share of
physical stressors and your different
Antics but for the most part our
stressors are psychological you know
it's the big deadline at work it's a
relationship concern it's something
about money or whatever it is and
the point that he makes is those
psychological stressors trigger the same
physiological response your brain is not
always so good at distinction being a
physical threat and a psychological
threat and if you're constantly
psychologically thread your body turns
the stress system on or stress response
on and never turns it off
so if I said you know what are the
symptoms of stressed people
you come up with a very familiar list if
they're sick all the time they have
problems with their gut they have
reproductive problems in extreme cases
there don't grow properly and so forth
so here's the punch line this is why I
think it's so interesting when you turn
on your stress response you tend to
shorten your time Horizon so you're the
zebra running away from line you're not
thinking about what am I going to be
doing in two weeks right you're thinking
like how am I going to survive 20
seconds
likewise if you're a human and you're
stressed you pull on your time Horizon
and that's a really interesting issue
for an investor because it can be the
case that as markets for example are
tumbling
and one could argue that your
opportunity set is becoming more
attractive because you're getting the
same asset at a lower price
everything inside you're gonna say man I
need to survive now I don't need to
worry about what's going to happen in
two or three years and I actually lived
through this I mean one of the big
drawdowns of 0809 in the financial
crisis we had certain you know some of
our investors were recommending stocks
to the portfolio manager and the
portfolio managers say like hey this
seems like a great idea over three years
but if I put this in my portfolio and it
goes down the next three months I'm
gonna be out of job right I'm gonna be
gone so this is another aspect of it is
this Equanimity right this ability to
sort of keep your eyes on the horizon
even when you're feeling the short-term
stress because we all do and that leaves
obviously you know what should you be
doing to do all the natural distressors
and so forth there's obviously a list of
things we could talk about there but to
me those are some of those qualities and
I guess the other thing I just say
overall I already mentioned it Tim but
I'll just emphasize it again is that
almost all the great investors I know
are just incredibly intellectually
curious and they want to understand how
things work they're willing to listen
and read and learn none of think they
figured it out right I don't think that
the game has been mastered they're
constantly trying to improve their
ability their craft and so forth and
that's why they're so much fun to be
around right for the most part because
they're they're typically very
interesting people because they read a
lot and think about how various ideas
that are swirling around there might
apply to what's going on in the world
today I'd love to chat a bit about some
of the content of your book think twice
which for people who haven't read it I
recommend and also has a great cover
quote from Billy Bean the general
manager of the Oakland A's who was or
then general manager who was
profiled and highlighted in Moneyball so
one hell of a quote so congratulations
for the cover quote as well my question
relates to
a component of the basic book
description so I'll just read this and
think twice Michael mobison shows you
how to recognize and avoid common mental
missteps including one misunderstanding
cause and effect linkages two
aggregating micro level Behavior to
predict macro level Behavior three this
is the one I want to talk about not
considering enough alternate
possibilities in making a decision and
for relying too much on Experts
not considering enough alternative
possibilities in making a decision
could you perhaps give some examples or
just recommendations for how people can
expand
the number of alternative possibilities
they can generate or consider in making
decisions
you know by the way think twice just the
premise of that is
that when you're faced with certain
types of situations those that you
described your mind naturally wants to
think about it one way
when there is a better way to think
about it it's often a better way to
think about so this is an encouraging to
say from time to time slow down
think twice right so that's where that
idea came from and you put your finger
on something so important right which is
again thinking about a wide range of
alternate possibilities and wider than
people typically think okay so what are
the techniques to allow people to do
that I'll mention maybe three of them
and I'll try to do this fairly quickly
the first is what we've already talked
about which is base rates
right so let's just pick something
specific you know you're trying to
figure out the growth rate of a company
or something something mundane like that
you might say well if the world is
consensus it's going to grow five
percent and if they kill it they're
going to grow eight percent and they do
really badly they'll grow two percent
right so they have this sort of Fairly
narrow band
then you might say to yourself well okay
let me look at other companies that were
sort of in the same situation same size
roughly the same Industries and look
what their actual growth rates were and
see if that's different and quite
commonly they're going to have much
bigger range of outcomes and that's
going to open up your mind to say okay
perhaps I should be thinking about
something more expansive than what I'm
doing now the second idea is concept
called a pre-mortem have you talked
about this no I think I discussed
pre-mortems well pre-mortems and their
opposite I think I discussed this with
role of both uh of Sequoia and there are
a few other folks but I think this is
worth revisiting
yeah and I'll be quick about it so we
all know about postmortem right so
postmortem the patient has died
and we sit around we say given the
information we have at the time could we
or should we have done something
differently to lead to a better outcome
right so we learn from our mistakes if
there are mistakes that were made and
we're all familiar with forecasting so
we're standing in the present peering on
to the Future a pre-mortem as the name
sort of implies is actually a third
exercise and by the way it's developed
by a psychologist named Gary Klein so if
you want to know more about pre-mortems
look up Gary Klein he wrote an hbr
article Harvard Business review article
about this specifically that allow you
to track this down so a pre-mortem is
that you're standing into the future you
pretend like you made the decision now
you're in the future say a year from now
and this decision's turned out horribly
it's embarrassing then each person
individually and again going back to our
concept of diversity each of us
individually writes down why this
decision turned out so poorly so
essentially we're documenting the ways
things can go bad and so what happens
often in organizations is we all
coalesce around making a decision making
a particular investment whatever is you
know and we're kind of optimistic and
we're sort of positive about it and the
pre-mortem again just draws out the
possibilities of things not going well
all and perhaps there is the junior
person in the room who didn't feel
emboldened to talk about this downside
scenario that no one seemed to be
contemplating but when he or she has to
write it out and we all read them that
opens up our minds to some degree the
last thing which is related to this is
just red teaming so most people are
familiar with this concept but comes
from military strategy originally I
think cyber security is a really good
example of it today but the blue team
defends the strategy the red team
attacks so if you're a general laying
out a strategy you say okay here's our
strategy if we were to attack ourselves
how would we do this so you're red
teaming so in cyber security you develop
your security and then you hire hackers
essentially to to hack yourself right to
see how vulnerable you are so again it's
just opening up your mind to other
possibilities in a way that that might
be difficult to do and one thing I want
to mention I think that's related to
this Tim that I think is so important
and it was part of your conversation you
had with Neil Ferguson and that was this
idea of counter factuals and you know I
think he said something which is correct
which is historians don't like really
like counterfactuals there are some
psychologists to talk a bit about
counterfactuals but a counterfactual
again is what didn't happen that could
have happened and I think it's just a
really important thing that once we all
understand that the future is pulsing
with possibilities and we even if we do
lay out these range of possibilities we
know that there are different paths the
world can take but once things happen
you know it's like we forget about all
the other possibilities right and there
are two things one's called hindsight
bias we started to think we knew it was
going to happen with a greater
probability that we actually did and the
other is called creeping determinism we
start to think that what happened was
the only thing that could have happened
and those are both very dangerous things
to fall into as well so it's this idea
of always keeping your mind open and
saying okay this turned out this way but
we understand there's a counterfactual
and things could have turned out
differently building off of learning
from failures and just
pre-mortem post-mortem all these rappers
we can put around mistakes and what we
can sort of learn or attempt to learn
ahead of time in terms of expanding
possibilities but also learning
afterwards
very clumsy way to lead into a very
simple question which is do you have any
favorite failures of your own so these
could be failures that ultimately seated
later successes things that taught you
disproportionate amount compared to
perhaps other mistakes or failures
you've experienced do you have any
favorite failures
so I you know mentioned Drexel Burnham
Lambert in this training program and all
the positive things that came out of it
and by the way you know David Epstein
why because it's not David Epson talked
about it but I I'm sure the idea has
been around is this idea of skill
matching which is you know you figure
out what you're likely to be okay at
where you can add some value that
benefit happened there but that job at
Drexel Burnham ultimately led to being a
stockbroker you know today to be a
financial advisor and Tim I was just an
abject failure at this job and you know
I resigned in quotation marks right but
effectively I was fired it was pretty
bad right like in other words I was
doing something I wasn't good at I
wasn't happy doing I was getting
negative feedback on that and so that
was I would call that a failure and that
was the culminating point of the
training program by the way other kids
kids other people in my training program
went on to be quite successful so it was
me not others and what I took away from
that was I'm probably not doing what I
should be doing and I should think more
about what kinds of things I could be
where I could be more valuable or more
useful and try to Pivot my
think twice over Reliance on Experts I'd
love to hear you expand on that and
maybe just defining experts as compared
to say people with experience we could
do first but I would love to know how
people can
counteract or how they should think
about over Reliance on Experts
the psychologist Greg northcraft has
this great distinction between
experience and expertise
he says an expert is someone who has a
predictive model that actually works
right and this is like a super big deal
in the world of investing so there are a
lot of people who have been around for a
long time they sort of gotten through
maybe a couple good breaks along the way
and they're experienced but they don't
necessarily have predictive models at
work whereas a really a true expert has
a predictive model that works I'm
increasingly skeptical about experts and
I think the pressure on Experts is
coming from two different directions the
first is algorithms and you know this
goes back to some famous work by Paul
meal from the 1950s on clinical
psychologists but just demonstrating
that it's almost always the case that
algorithms so basically rules that we
write down outperform many experts
and many different fields by the way
it's actually even more interesting than
that because sometimes you can go to
somebody and say tell me how you do this
tell me how you think about what you're
doing and you can actually write out a
bunch of rules and they're telling you
the rules right and then if you actually
compare the person with the model that
the person created the model does better
the person itself right so it's not the
slippage is not the way they're thinking
about the world the slippages are not
executing right and this is the law of
the work on the checklist and so and so
forth but anyway so that's the first
thing is there can be algorithms and I
think what we're seeing in our world is
more and more of these now they're
they're downsized algorithm but more and
more these algorithms and then the other
one Tim is what we've already talked
about which is in complex domains
I think in many instances there's a lot
of evidence that crowds the wisdom of
crowds is better than in than experts in
quotes and this goes back to we talked
about Phil tetlock and the work on super
forecasting a few moments ago you know
filter locks the first book I read of
his was in the mid I think 2006 or 2007
called expert political judgment and
there he actually took about 400 experts
asked him to make very specifically
these are Masters PhD level people right
at the top of their field and asked them
to make very specific predictions in
economic political and social domains
and then kept track and found that they
were you know not much better than
chance in making their predictions and
by the way they're like you and me when
they get something wrong they have a
Litany of excuses right like oh you know
you just wait or you know oh had this
happened I would have been right about
this one of my favorites is somebody
said like my prediction was so important
to change the course of world events I
was like okay so that's an interesting
one that's also interesting so I think
that the wisdom of crowds can outperform
him so I think that's leading to this
idea called the expert squeeze but in
certain domains again you should listen
to experts one of the ways that you can
figure this out is to say like okay if I
appeal to a bunch of different experts
are they going to basically give me the
same answer right and so tomorrow you
want to say hey how's the weather going
to be tomorrow you can turn on various
TV channels probably a couple internet
sources and you're going to get roughly
the same thing right so those experts
are going to converge on the same
Solution by contrast if you say again
geopolitical stuff or you know what will
the price of oil be and whatever you can
get some very well qualified and
credentialed experts with different
views they're going to say things that
can be potentially wildly different and
so you know one example for instance
where this is a really big deal today is
stuff like climate change so even if you
and I agree on the inputs and we're both
experts you know we may both build
models that are on some level credible
but they may generate very different
outcomes and so what do you do with that
so that's an area where you just we're
our experts where do you have to put the
question well I suppose a lot of folks
rely on experts in many many different
domains and on the let's just say if
they're trying to look at
some way of analytically chewing on all
the data from experts to make a decision
or from one or two select experts on the
opposite end of the spectrum there's
this term that gets used by many people
I think very haphazardly which is
intuition however one of the questions
that I suppose broad questions I had
that I want to explore with you was how
you think about intuition question mark
end of question and broadly here's one
from Josh which is how can an awareness
of cognitive biases be internalized into
intuition
and then he added to that ensomatically
accessed but we can potentially hit
pause on that you and I both know Josh
but how do you think about it yeah
it's an absolutely fascinating topic and
Here Again by the way I'll mention Gary
Klein the pre-mortem guy has been
you know pretty strong advocate for
something called naturalistic decision
making which relies a lot on intuition
Danny Kahneman who won the Nobel prize
in economics as a psychologist has been
one who's pointed out the heuristics and
biases and things like prospect theory
and so forth so they they were sort of
on opposite ends of this and
interestingly they did an adversarial
collaboration in 2009 they published a
paper called a failure to disagree so
that's interesting Kahneman and Klein so
Tim I would take one step back and say
using some language from psychology this
is brilliant branding by the way there
are two systems of the Mind system one
and system two it's just like inside
outside views like those guys need
marketing they need a marketing
department over those psychology
departments so system one as you know
people talked a lot about this it's your
experiential system so it's fast it's
automatic it's difficult to train but it
basically runs your life for the most
part system two is slow it's purposeful
it's deliberate it's costly right you
have to recruit it often it's lazy it
doesn't really want to do much work
and I would say that intuition is a
situation where you've trained your
system one in a particular domain to be
very effective for that to work I would
argue that you need to have a system so
this is the system level that it's
fairly linear and stable
so linear in that sense I mean really
the cause and effect are pretty clear
and stable means the basic rules of the
game don't change all that much
so if you have those conditions and by
the way even driving your car you've got
some intuitions about how that works you
can get around that's fine if I put you
in a stressful driving situation of
course like bad weather or certain
speeds whatever you're what you know to
do is going to not be sufficient to get
the job done so
um I had this interesting conversation
with Josh about this specifically by the
way the art of learning is fabulous I'm
a huge fan and by the way just in awe of
his accomplishments all his conscience
but certainly when you think about two
domains chess and martial arts for
instance and he was you know working
with different investors and he he would
say to him he told me he's like I would
tell them like rely on your intuition I
was like dude I don't know if that's
good advice right and the reason is I'm
like for you Josh you happen to Excel
and become world class in two domains
that were linear and stable chess is a
perfect example it's almost like the
canonical example where you know experts
exist they're Grand Masters they I mean
all that kind of stuff
you know they're just operating at a
different level than certainly I am
and then you go to the martial arts and
I just remember reading in the art of
learning he's got this interesting
section toward the end where I think he
was in some sort of like world
championships for Tai Chi and it was in
Taiwan and and so he goes there and I
don't know enough about how all this
works but I I hope I get this roughly
right is apparently they decided to
change the rules to change the like a
starting position for engagement and the
size of the Ring which seemed like a
really big deal so he's been training
using these other things and all of a
sudden essentially my my system didn't
became unstable right likewise mother if
you said chess you know we're going to
make the board now 10 by 10 and the
pieces move differently right all the
expertise of the grand Masters would go
out the window
so I think that intuition tends to be
way because we all Feel It by the way we
all have that sensation of an automatic
answer that comes to us
but I think it tends to be way
overweighted and you know the other
thing we have another problem with
intuition is a big sampling bias problem
right which is like people say like how
did you come up with this idea I'm like
I just came to me in a Flash like
intuitively right and we forget about
all the dumb ideas that came to people
they don't talk about right so there's a
sampling problem as well so that that to
me would be the thing on intuition that
I think is really important so it's not
that it doesn't exist it absolutely does
it can be through this training now this
goes back I mean Josh's question is a
little bit another level right which is
how do you eradicate biasiveness and I
do think it's almost part and parcel of
the system right because if you're
learning
in one of these stable and linear
systems your failures become it's much
more it's easier to point out your
failures I think or your mistakes or
your errors than it is perhaps in other
systems so I think they kind of get
weeded out to some degree we obviously
have these also I mentioned before like
overconfidence and and confirmation bias
we have biases and all sorts of other
things but those tend to be more uh
relevant for for more open domains for
saying by the way I should ask you Tim
so would you say like when you think
about your experience as a wrestler
let's just focus on like wrestling
perhaps or even dancing but wrestling do
you feel like you trained yourself in
such a way that you not to say it was
perfectly automatic you may have had a
little dialogue in your head but but you
sort of knew what you were doing and how
to do it fast and hard and accurately
would you say that I would say that uh
probably even more so in Judo but I I I
I certainly think I went from say
unconscious incompetence to conscious
incompetence to conscious competence to
unconscious or kind of automatic
confidence which is part of the parcel
of competing
in probably I would have to imagine most
sports not all but speed is a deciding
factor
so I do feel like I got there
yeah no I think that's and that's a good
example where and again like I don't
know exactly how the rules are Judo but
again if I change the rules somehow or
even in all you know any sports you
watch popular sports like you know
basketball or ice hockey or football
whatever is if you change the rules it
does change you know it takes people
time to adapt and and quotes retrain in
order to internalize and like you said
you go from that awkward phase of like
I'm thinking about what I'm doing to
sort of being automatic and I I it
should provide maybe a little bit more
context to you for why I'm asking about
intuition certainly I'm asking because I
wanted to
build off of what Josh had had put forth
and I know he thinks very deeply about
different systems of thinking and is is
truly
a spectacular
competitor and is
almost just beyond comparison for me and
his ability to systematically
deconstruct and become world class in
different domains I mean he's doing it
with foil boarding right now and to
watch his progress over the last few
years has just been
astonishing quite frankly I've also
started to ask other podcast guests and
friends in different domains about
intuition not because I'm looking to
justify it in any kind of new age way or
overweight it but I'm curious how
perhaps put a different way they
utilize different systems of thinking in
their own lives and so had for instance
John vervaky who's a professor of a few
different things cognitive science among
them at the University of Toronto and he
talked about intuition as implicit
learning so a pattern recognition and
how that can be well-shaped or poorly
shaped I'm using my words and not his I
am this isn't a question I suppose more
of a confession of context which is just
to say I am increasingly interested
though
in very fast decision making
understanding that there is a sampling
bias right it's very easy to remember
the handful of times where you come up
with something brilliant very quickly
and subconsciously or consciously
dismiss all the stupid things that you
came up with but nonetheless an area of
Interest I guess partially because I've
just focused so much on the analytical
side and the more laborious forms of
arriving at answers that that's
something I'm deeply interested in
but I do think I mean even your point on
implicit I don't know what your exact
phrase was but implicit it certainly
would fit what I would believe about
this which is again often experts if you
ask them how they're conceptualizing
things they're I'm not sure they're
completely aware of how they're doing it
right even things like chunking you know
chunking with something that was
observed by psychologists looking at
chess players I don't know the players
themselves were saying this is how I'm
doing it so it's super interesting yeah
no I think it's super interesting how
the mind works and experts they
definitely work in a different way than
the rest of us but I'll just say like in
the world of investing you know
investors often talk about this idea of
pattern recognition and again pattern
recognition if your system has certain
characteristics I think works great the
question again is and investing is
how do I parse what I think would be
lend itself to where pattern recognition
will be effective versus where it's
unlikely to be effective and that's
that's the interesting question that's
the line I'm interested in in
understanding I'm similarly interested
well let me bring up maybe just one or
two final questions and we can certainly
go anywhere else that you might like to
go but this one is less conceptual more
personal so this is something that came
to mind for me but also came up with
some of your students in your tribute
video
and that is time management so you have
jobs you write books you read a lot of
books you have five kids
the list goes on and on and I would love
to
hear any advice or tenets or rules you
have for
time management maybe that's the wrong
term to use life management perhaps you
mentioned one of them before we started
recording which was being religious
about sleep I don't know if that's one
of the pillars but how on Earth do you
juggle all of these things and still
seem to have a reservoir of energy left
over it's pretty staggering to me
yeah it's certainly not as impressive as
it looks but let me just say that I'll
start with
my life partner my wife you know and I
really mean a partner and I've always
thought this is at least my own view I
don't I don't know people have talked
about there so this is how they feel but
it's almost like an amplifier and if you
have a really good relationship and
someone that works well with you and
you're compatible and you have you know
same sort of sets of goals it just
amplifies everything and makes
everything better and I've had that so
we've been married you know 30 plus
years and that is the number one single
factor I would have to say just being
with a partner who's really supportive
and understanding and you know even like
for years when we go off on vacation she
would always allow me a couple hours to
go off and read stuff and something like
that so just being thoughtful about that
so that is first and foremost and
dealing with a lot of stuff including
with the kids and so forth the second
thing is I don't know like I just been
doing it I've been doing this for a very
long time right so it sounds like you're
reading off all these things it's just
it's over a very long period of time I
will just say that I enjoy a lot of this
stuff so I really enjoy learning things
I enjoy reading things I enjoy trying to
understand things at first principles I
enjoy trying to track ideas down to
their Genesis to understand where they
came from and how they got to where they
are today
I also enjoy writing I'm not that good
at it but I need to keep working on that
by the way was John McVey your professor
he was and I still much like some of
your students were saying that their
friend took your course 15 years before
and kept all the notes I still have all
of my notes from John McPhee's seminar
at Princeton
well I read I mean I just read I'm
embarrassed to say I got to it late but
I read draft number four last year and I
was just like
it's so on something that looks like
brilliant and nonetheless like so
discouraging it's like this guy is like
so off the charts so good right where
you read Michael another Princeton guy
Michael Lewis or you read these guys
you're like oh my God it's spectacular
right but I think this idea of
organizing your thoughts and trying to
communicate him effectively that's also
uh very motivating I will say this and
this is something I share with my
students and I try to embody this to the
best of my ability it's sort of the
foundation you know I use it the lame
term but like a mental athlete but like
if I were trying to compete at a high
level as an athlete what kinds of things
would I do and I practice and I would
make sure I was getting my rest I would
recover I'll make sure I'm eating
properly and so forth so like what would
that be for cognitive tasks for me and
by the way I really appreciate that you
spent so much time with Matthew Walker
and brought his ideas to the world
because I think his stuff is really
really powerful and in particular just
to zoom in on this idea of the cognitive
performance well let's just say
negatively the cognitive degradation if
you're not sleeping properly is just
staggering right so to me the
Cornerstone is sleep and I really do try
to focus on that pretty religious about
the sleep thing and I'm an eight-hour
guy that really does make a difference
for me and then for me what follows is
exercise I've always been a lifelong
athlete so I've always enjoyed movement
but for me that's really important to be
able to move every day and be very
active and I don't know that I do
everything Tim that you're telling me I
should do but I do you know I lift and I
can mix it up a little bit more and then
for me actually diet and I try to be
very careful with diet too but but that
is actually falls if the first two are
in shape like the last one seems to go
pretty much it's like if I'm not
sleeping or exercise and everybody else
goes to hell in a hand basket for me
personally so those are the things so
that that allows me to perform I think
to operate at a fairly high level for me
now I'll just one quick story on this is
that in the late 1990s I was at Credit
Suisse as you mentioned and I had a
brief stint as a job called the product
manager which meant I ran the morning
research meeting which started at 7 30
in the morning which meant I had to get
in there a little bit earlier we live in
Connecticut so I had to commute in so I
was getting up really early every day
and with five kids it's hard to go to
bed super early right so I was just
massively sleep deprived and I signed a
book without Rappaport to write the
first edition of expectations investing
so I was like all right I'm gonna do
this I got clearance from my boss I'm
like I'm gonna work from home you know
like three days a week just back
whatever this is like 1999 2000. and so
what did I do right I slept an hour more
spent an hour more of my time but I
slept an hour more I'm like oh my God
this is how I'm supposed to feel like at
three o'clock in the afternoon I'm still
productive like for years for years
literally like after noon I was like a
basket case right I would I could talk
to people but I could certainly not do
any hard lifting cognitive work whereas
correcting all that has really made a
huge difference so that was works for me
now I would just say the other thing is
you know because people often comment
like how much I read and whatever I
actually don't do a lot of other things
too so I don't I've never seen Game of
Thrones you know for instance I'm not
proud of that so it's these there's some
trade-offs right just to be clear about
all these things so people focus on one
aspect of something without looking at
the the deficits in other categories
it's very important to balance all that
up what are other things on your not
to-do list for you personally
okay so for me the things that I try to
avoid so so first of all I just say that
this by Constitution this is just the
keys that were handed to me I don't have
an addictive behavior so that really
helps a lot and things and I just so I'm
not for example a drinker a big drinker
very light social drinker so I think
alcohol itself is a huge thing and I
would not do more of it so that's one
big one
yeah the other one is just it would be
time allocation and just be like how I'm
spending time again it's not good
because I'm not up on all the things in
pop culture and so forth but I think
you'll be fine yeah yeah well I don't
know yeah I hope so five kids any
resources you'd recommend or thoughts on
parenting that you'd like to share with
people who are in earlier innings
people often ask this question like if
you change your mind about anything
the one thing I don't know that I
completely changed my mind but the one
thing that I found to be really
interesting and to some degree
liberating is the work of Judith Rich
Harris I don't know Judith Richardson's
work
and her first book is called the nurture
assumption and then I think she wrote a
second book called No to alike she
passed away a few years ago
first of all her background is very
interesting because she was sort of
shunned from a PhD program in psychology
but went on to like write textbooks it
was basically an independent scholar
I mean one of the premises I think most
people operate with is that parents are
really important in how their children's
turn out
and I think what her work shows and by
the way the fascinating literature in
twin studies right twins separated at
Birth I think just demonstrates for the
most part that you obviously you need to
put a roof over a kid's head and love
them and feed them and do all those good
things but for the most part there's a
big chunk of nature that's important in
how people turn out that to me was a
really interesting one because when you
have five kids you have Under One Roof
you have a lot of diversity and their
own interests and capabilities and and
so on so forth and then the other one I
this is probably totally pop but I
always like this book called parent
Effectiveness training p18 what I liked
about it was the the guy I hope I'm
getting this accurate presenting this
accurately
but but the author argues like you know
you should think about and this is not
when they're babies but when they're a
little older you know are you like when
are the problems your problems and one
of the problems the kids problems by the
way this is a little bit of the Jonathan
Height work incidentally sort of free
range kid thing right so when is it your
problem when is it the kids problem if
it's your problem then you say to the
kid listen I need you to help me to get
this thing solved so that you're asking
for the help from the kid but it's your
problem if it's the kids problem the
natural inclination of parents is to
solve the problem because you know how
to do it rather than let the kids solve
the problem for themselves and you might
say something like this is your problem
I need you to solve it I'm here to help
you if you'd like but you can do with
this kid with five years old right I'm
here to help you if you need help but I
want you to figure this out on your own
so this idea of again taking the
initiative thinking about alternatives
for yourself as a little kid even
I just always like that distinction
that's another and there's a lot of
other stuff in the book but that that to
me is one idea I've always thought about
is is this my problem is this the kids
problem it's the kid's problem let me
make sure that I let him or her solve
the problem me to help if they need it
but only playing that secondary role
well thank you for answering that as
much as you dislike talking about
yourself I may force you to do it one or
two more times complex adaptive systems
I'm curious to know outside of business
and investing
how being exposed to the Santa Fe
Institute
and or complex adaptive systems and
learning more about such systems has
just changed how you look at the world
or experience the world
unbelievable totally changes your point
of view on everything I think it makes
you much more circumspect right
you know I think you recently were
talking to Jonathan height and I think
he kept talking about this basic concept
of when you're messing with a complex
system I think the big point and there's
a chapter about this and think twice I
think we use the example of Yellowstone
National Park
is that it's very difficult to manage a
complex adaptive system right so in
other words the perturbations the
outcomes are not corresponding always
with the size of the perturbation which
is really hard for people so classic
examples
ecosystems economies all the climate
issues these are all complex adaptive
systems and they're just very difficult
to think through and manage and even to
model to some degree
so yeah I think once you have that
framework in your mind by the way for me
just professionally this is I think the
best way to think about markets
specifically and why again markets are
hard to beat which they are but why they
periodically go Haywire which they do I
think it's just a lens through which to
see a lot of different things in life in
a way that's I think more representative
now I think the downside is that the
recognition I think it makes you feel
like you have less control which is I
think fundamentally correct but I think
that's in some ways liberating and so as
you look at these systems and you try to
improve the world and people always talk
about you know unintended consequences
but if I make if I have an intervention
or I try to engineer an intervention
what is the unattended consequence can I
think about those things and
understanding if you're messing with a
complex adaptive system that's a
non-linear system it's just gonna it's
gonna happen
and so you find that freeing because
you're not grasping too tightly to the
misfounded belief that you can control
these things precisely yeah precisely
precisely it's interesting if you're
trying to understand a system is it
useful to be able to describe it in
terms that seem to be reflective of
what's going on and I think that's
probably right so I think this is just a
better description of a lot of systems
that we deal with and we don't
necessarily
describe things properly so I think this
I think this helps in that regard too
I'm ready to dig in after being
waterboarded with all the the value of
studying complex adaptive systems from
Dr Bill Gurley and and yourself exactly
I'm sold so I need to sounds like well I
don't know would if I wanted to read
about complex adaptive systems is let's
see I'm trying to find the title of the
book complexity that came up earlier is
that the place to start or are there
other books you would suggest starting
with
there's a book by Melanie Mitchell who
is now resident faculty at the Santa Fe
Institute called complexity a guided
tour
and it's more than just the narrow
concept of complex adaptive systems but
there's tons of stuff in there that's
absolutely fascinating and I would just
say like every thinking person certainly
scientifically literate person if you
can grasp the ideas in Melanie
Mitchell's book complexity that would be
a great start there are a lot of
resources on the website at the Santa Fe
Institute so that is Santa
fe.edu so I would check that out as well
but if you really just go to a bookstore
or go to Amazon and type in complexity
or complex adaptive systems a bunch of
stuff we'll show up Melanie by the way
one of her one of the people she worked
with was John Holland and John Holland
he may have coined the term complex
adaptive system but John Holland is also
like another he he's also passed away
but a Titan in this whole area as well
so I wanted to
perhaps rap with the question of the
metaphorical billboard and I'll put this
in context and if this is a dead end
I'll take the blame for it and the
questions is is this supposed pretty
simple it's simple to ask which is if
you had a billboard on which you could
put anything metaphorically speaking to
get a message or quote a question an
image anything out to
billions of people ideally
non-commercial what might you put on
that billboard does anything come to
mind
one thing that comes to mind is there's
a quote from Phil tutlock's book Phil
and Dan Gardner super forecasting
there's just a quote which I love and I
find myself repeating it often
and it says beliefs are hypotheses to be
tested not Treasures to people I love
that that's great beliefs are hypotheses
to be tested not Treasures to be
protected now
we all have treasured beliefs right to
some degree but to the degree to which
we can really like you said sort of have
a light touch on our beliefs
a light hold on our beliefs I think
that's a great way to try to go through
the world
so I love that and I think that would be
great for people can I mention another
one again this might this is too wordy
but there's a there's a really
interesting book called the psychology
of intelligence analysis do you know
that you probably don't talk by Richards
Hewer it's called the psychology of
intelligence analysis and the author is
Richard's Hewer and there's actually a
PDF of it which you can get through the
CIA website so if you just do you Google
you know viewer h-e-u-e-r
the psychology intelligence analysis and
then CIA it'll pop up some more and I'm
going to paraphrase this it's toward the
beginning of the book but I always love
this too and it goes along these lines
he says analysts who know the most about
a situation
have the most to unlearn when the world
changes
it's kind of a related theme right which
is
Phil tadlock talked a lot about this in
expert political judgment you know
you're an expert on the Cold War and
you've been studying you know U.S Soviet
relations for a long time and all of a
sudden the Berlin Wall comes down and
there's a whole new reality what are you
gonna do right you have to unlearn all
the stuff that you know and start anew
and that's just really difficult for
people to do so one of my takeaways in
that latter why I think that one's
interesting is that's why the beginner's
mind is so important and as I always
like to say in organizations what's bad
about young people is they don't know
anything and what's good about young
people is they don't know anything right
so this idea can we have people around
us can we surround ourselves with people
who are willing to ask the naive
question or willing to have fresh eyes
or are willing to not carry around
baggage perhaps and that baggage may
have been very helpful for us at some
juncture but to not have that baggage
and so that to me would be another you
know this idea of trying to avoid this
situation where you fail to unlearn
based on your past what a great place to
begin to wind to a close so Michael
people can find you on Twitter at MJ
mobison that's
m-a-u-b-o-u-s-s-i-n your website
michaelmobison.com
where should people start with respect
to your books if they are a lay person
not focused on investing but would like
to become better thinkers where would
you suggest they start and then for
professional investors who are new to
your work or people who would like to
become better investors where should
they start
for decision making so the more fun ones
would be think twice and the success
equation
which is about specifically the topic of
luck and skill so there is investing
stuff in there but there's a lot of
sports stuff and business stuff now
what's interesting I'll tell you these
are all these little backstories so I
wrote think twice and I had a chapter
about luck there's a chapter in about
luck and skill toward the end but I had
it as chapter two
and my editor goes oh you know I don't
know like this seems like a little bit
boring No One's Gonna really care about
this like you could keep it but like put
it at the end you know nobody reads a
whole book okay so so I put at the end
and then I sent out the book and a bunch
of friends contact me people I like and
of course they're gonna say nice things
but there's a bunch of people like a
bunch of people said to me like you know
that was fine it was all good but boy
that lucky skill stuff I wish you talked
more about that so I was like oh man I
knew that was good right because the Big
Brown story we did lead the book with a
big brown story and so that got me
thinking more about what can we do with
with that luck and skill topic now Nasim
talab wrote a book called a full by
Randomness in 2001 and I have to say you
know Michael Luce's book Moneyball I was
a lacrosse player played Lacross the
college so like I was never like a big
baseball guy but I read that book in the
hands of Michael Lewis that topic was
absolutely fascinating and got me very
excited about thinking more about sports
analytics so I delved into that
Community a little bit and you know
there's a ton because it's obviously a
very there's a lot of data and more more
constrained systems there's a lot those
guys can talk about with luck and skill
so that end up being the success
equation which is a book about luck and
skill so if your broader decision making
think twice if you're interested in luck
and skill particularly as a topic the
success equation I mentioned already
more than you know some of the greatest
hits of the consonant Observer that one
is going to be it's a little bit all
over it was the most commercially
successful of my books but it's a little
bit like all over the place so if you
like just picking up a book and reading
a random chapter without a lot of
structure because I end up putting it
just in sections but that's the book to
read so these are 1500 word chapters
that you're not going to get bogged down
by can you repeat the title one more
time
yeah more than you know got it yep
yep and then the final one is
expectations investing there are two
versions of it by the way think about
this Tim this is amazing the first we
signed the contract for this book in
1999 right the stock market's roaring
the economy is doing great the book came
out September 9th
no September 10 2001. so the day before
National tragedy which happened to be in
the middle of a three-year bear market
and stock market so it was like timing
is horrible anyway expectations
investing and so we did another version
of it 20 years later and that came out
in the fall of 2021 so expectations
revised and so if you're a serious
investor and by the way there's a
website that goes with that call
expectationsvesting.com which also
includes a bunch of downloadable Excel
tutorials it brings those ideas to life
and I'll just mention I already
mentioned I'll Rapaport and creating
shareholder value he's an extraordinary
guy he's now in his 90s I talked him
very frequently he's fabulous his mind
is going he's working on multiple
projects his mind is going great it's
been throughout my career knowing him
for 30 plus years a complete Delight
working with him but uh it's not stopped
it's been so much fun so I'll just say
that was for the series I mean what a
gift to be
and what a turn of
fate to be introduced to his work and
have it impact you so deeply when you're
just getting started and then to get to
the point where you're collaborating
that's just incredible it's just
wonderful
you're absolutely right and again as we
know we all have our lucky turns I met
him first in May 1991 and I gotta
remember somebody called me up and
they're like
Professor rap report is going to be in
New York he has 20 minutes to meet you
like you could bow and I was like oh my
God it's like I'm not worthy kind of
scene and you know I hit it off with him
and he invited me to join some executive
programs at Kellogg in the early 1990s
so I was a young guy I was in my 20s and
I think it was you know kind of risky
for him to do that and that's where that
relationship got going so yeah it's been
incredible and by the way as someone
who's tried to teach I've now I'm in my
31st year Columbia business school
someone who tries to teach it's
extraordinary because if I need how to
explain something
all I need to do is call him up and we
talk it through and he he's just such a
brilliant teacher you know he sort of
helps me understand what I'm talking
about and get to the right place anyway
these are the kinds of relationships
that are so valuable yeah what a
beautiful relationship Michael this has
been a lot of fun I've taken copious
notes I have a lot to read and I really
appreciate you taking the time is there
anything that you would like to add any
closing comments requests of the
audience
complaints that you'd like to Lodge
formally anything at all that comes to
mind that you'd like to say
I think we covered a lot of terrain Tim
and I really appreciate first of all I
want to say how much of a fan of yours
that I am and how much I've learned from
your podcast over the years and there's
so many things I admire about what you
do in particular that I sometimes feel I
am trying to contribute in a way to help
people think better and work better
especially in the domain of investing
but I really appreciate that you're
actually a guy doing stuff all the time
so um I'll just say that as as a point
of admiration and I leave this as sort
of the final thing I say say to my
students but this idea that
recognizing that if you're in a domain
that's largely cognitive
what would you do to try to improve your
performance we talked about sleep and
exercise and diet but I just think that
these are things people should take
really seriously to be really good
performers so that's what I probably
would leave with is just to make sure
that people to the best of their we all
you know you have kids running around
things happen in life I totally get it
but your ability to do those kinds of
things that's really that's awesome
absolutely well thank you Michael for
saying that and for being so game to
cover so much train and to everybody
listening we'll have links to everything
we discussed in the show notes as usual
at tim.blog slash podcast and if you
can't spell mobicen then just type in
Michael and chances are you'll find
Michael right away and until next time
thanks for tuning in be just a bit
Kinder than necessary to other people
and to yourself and remember if you were
doing a lot of work cognitively you're a
cognitive athlete and your brain is not
separate from the rest of your body so
you need to mind your p's and q's when
it comes to the basics the fundamentals
and that includes sleep so thank you for
listening everyone and thank you Michael
and until next time this is Tim Ferriss
signing off
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bold Friday easy to sign up
easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been and spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus the 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
this episode is brought to you by house
of macadamia's delicious and nutritious
nuts holy hell folks I tell you these
things are delicious I've been gobbling
them all day anyway I love macadamia
nuts and have been enjoying them often
since keto expert Dr Dominic D'Agostino
recommended them way back on the podcast
in 2015. it tastes great and they have
more healthy monounsaturated fat than
both olive oil and avocados 27 fewer
grams of carbs than almonds and more
than 50 percent fewer grams of carbs
than cashews they're the perfect low
carb keto friendly nutty snack in fact I
just ate a handful of lightly white
chocolate dusted dare I say macadamia's
about an hour ago to keep me going
through the afternoon until dinner it is
the perfect snack for me now we'll say
this house of macadamias produces the
best tasting macadamia nuts I've ever
eaten that I've ever had by far that's
due in part to their location in the
mupumalanga province of South Africa
which provides the ideal temperature
altitude soil composition in rainwater
and pristine Mountain Water for growing
you guessed it macadamias House of
macadamias have partnered with the
largest Macadamia producer in the world
comprising 94 independent farmers in
South Africa which gets them first pick
of the highest quality macadamia nuts in
the region to make their one-of-a-kind
snacks like their vegan paleo and keto
friendly chocolate dipped macadamias it
really took their time to get all of
this right and they've done more than
two years of flavor testing and you can
taste that in each packet you consume
and I've had two of those today
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show can
use code tim20 that's Tim 2-0 to get 20
off of all orders Plus for a limited
time a free premium extraversion cold
pressed all the things macadamia oil
with any order valued at twenty dollars
I love macadamia oil has a very high
smoke point you can use it for all sorts
of things it is perfect for cooking
salad dressings and much more so that's
code 1020 for 20 off plus a free x
virgin cold-pressed macadamia oil with
every order visit
houseofmacademias.com Tim to discover
some of the most delicious and
nutritious nuts on the planet one more
time that's House of macadamias.com Tim
foreign
[Applause]